the fire broke out on Thursday evening
quickly spreading through the unlicensed
orphanage run by a u.s. religious group
just outside Haiti's capital authorities
say seven of those who perished were
babies or toddlers along with six who
were roughly 10 or 11 years of age it
reportedly took firefighters around an
hour and a half to reach the scene we
did not have the means to intervene all
the way off the floor we were taking out
the children who were conscious and
making sure to get them to the hospital
unfortunately when they got to the
hospital they did not receive any help
how the place started is still being
investigated but a worker at the home
said candles were being used for light
after a generator failed the Church of
Bible understanding is reported to have
failed sanitary inspections in the past
because of overcrowding and a lack of
trained staff Pennsylvania organization
which runs this and another home in
Haiti says it houses close to 200
children in what it calls a Christian
training program in Haiti orphans are
often children that families can't
afford to feed they come to places like
this to get an education and safe
housing workers from the home are in
shock I was eating soup and I run fast
to get there when I arrived I did not
find any of my children I saw only three
or four of the younger ones alive the
government has closed around 160
orphanages in the past five years and
hundreds more operate without official
authorization Haiti's president job now
moiez tweeted his condolences saying I'm
deeply saddened by the death of about 10
children as a result of a fire last
night at the orphanage I urged the
authorities to urgently investigate in
order to establish the causes of this
tragedy the authorities say they're
seeking shelter for the children that
survived Ana Gallacher al Jazeera